how are you doing today sir
i'm doing well how are you i'm doing
excellent it is very nice all of your
figurines behind you they're pretty cool
uh yeah it's a distraction from this it
works
first of all let me say i saw the first
i saw eight episodes of foundation and
uh yeah listen if you give me access to
a sci-fi show
the button gets pushed very quickly did
you binge them
uh yeah in a span of two and a half days
i didn't i didn't just watch them back
to back no no you don't want to do that
actually i'm sort of i i favor the um
you know give yourself a week to
entertain the story and your imagination
then get the next one then again the
next one but i understand this is very
bingeable i have to say
oh actually listen i have to say i feel
really bad for the people that are going
to watch it weekly because there's so
much you want to know where it's going
to go but i i did it because i'm talking
to david today and i wanted to be able
to ask
you know um
to withhold the gratification no
[Laughter]
not even a little so listen uh this is
my kind of series i had i i mean i love
this kind of stuff and you're great in
it uh
jumping to the beginning what was it
about and it's a little generic but what
was it about this project that said i
want to you know i want to be part of it
and the fact that it could last for a
long time
you never know you know it could be a
big part of your life or it could just
be one year
well i mean you know i said david he
pitched me this story that unfolded over
a thousand years it was this very
ambitious epic tale there was a
about the survival of the human race and
you know i was my character was right
dead center at it he was the lead
character and he was the the heart of
that story so
um
i was looking for something to sort of
follow chernobyl up with he sent me the
next the first two scripts
um and they were beautifully written so
you know yeah i was hooked
once you signed on obviously there's a
lot of books did you feel like i need to
read everything or
um i'm not sure how familiar you were
with the material going in
i wasn't i'll be honest with you but
once i signed on i went and caught up i
mean i basically
read
in chronological order not the order the
books were written so that i was aware
of harry's story up to the point that i
was now responsible for portraying him
um one of the things i love learning
about like the behind the scenes of the
making of a series things you might not
know what do you think might surprise uh
fans a foundation to learn about the
making of the series
i mean you know it was an epic journey
literally an epic journey we were in
iceland we were in berlin
we're in the west coast of ireland the
east coast of ireland we were in malta
we were in the ventura we were on
tanerife i mean you know it was an epic
journey
it in that that's something when i was
watching the first two episodes i was
like oh they spent all the money in the
world to make this show because it looks
massive what i mean could you sort of
talk about the fact that these sets and
everything that that is
it's very impressive
i think listen if you're if your
ambition is to tell this story
then
you have to tell the story you have to
support it in every aspect and it has it
has been it is supported in every aspect
you know
now
one of the decisions that they made
which was an exciting decision was we
want this thing to feel tangible and
real so we want sets we want them we
want people to be living in a real space
rather than in a digitized space
and so as much as possible you had that
um that practical aspect that you can
tell as you're looking at it and you see
the way that the people are interacting
with that space and that was great for
us
and again you know one of the things
that they did was on the spaceships is
they came up with this really unique way
of trying of how to
what you're looking at outside of
the um the spaceport windows was you
know it wasn't blue screen they came up
with a different way of doing it so it
felt again it felt real
i love that on the series the super
power is math
it's uh
i just i love it it's not some mutant
ability it's math you know and this goes
into one of the things that's so great
about the show is that it doesn't dumb
itself down for the audience there's
time jumps there's multiple planets and
there's no exposition dumps which is
another thing i love it's just smart
writing can you sort of talk about that
well i think that you know that's an
interesting thing that you say because
that was actually the chief challenge as
an actor of playing harry selden was
that there could be a reliance on using
that character as an exposition dump um
because he knows so much and there are
certain responsibilities that you have
to have in terms of of of catching
people up but
and my thing was
look
that's that that's fine and they think
we could figure out what's necessary but
it must come out of a a need
of a desire of whoever's in that scene
whereas that piece of information has to
be revealed or you cannot progress
whatever's going on between these two
people cannot progress so you know it
can't be just people idly talking so you
know and and i think i feel like you
know we we we dug into it and we david
and i chatted about it and he came up
with some really really good solutions
about how to satisfy both knees not just
us as a character us as the actors but
also the desire for the narrative of the
story which needs its own propulsion
yeah i i think he did a very good job
with that stuff the um i'm a big fan of
your work and your acting
and i am and i love talking to actors
about a little bit how they prepare for
like a big scene so say you're filming
something that's really gonna take it
out of you on a monday emotionally
dramatic whatever it may be how do you
typically like to prepare for that scene
are you like days in advance thinking
about it or do you sort of channel all
that nervous energy the day before
and sort of switch it on do you know
what i mean
you have to
first of all
you have to have prepared that scene
at least a week or longer beforehand so
that your it's it can has it has the
opportunity i mean properly so that you
can do it backwards and forwards in
terms of it's not an exercise in memory
then your so your subconscious can start
to interact with you and start to inform
you about things that didn't occur to
you so you can have intuitions about it
then you try and get a really good
night's sleep the night before which you
always fail you're up all night
so you go in and you're exhausted when
you go in there but you've got all this
nervous energy going as well
and um and then you know you just you
hope it works it's always it's always
jumping off the high dive you don't know
if you're going to belly flop or
execute properly you never know
and then um you know hopefully it goes
well enough that you won't be too
embarrassed when it's broadcast and you
get a really good night's sleep that
night
it's so i can't imagine
i yeah i don't know how you guys do it
who are you know because but ultimately
you are like all this work let's use
foundation all this work has been done
for years in advance
all to that moment on set where you're
delivering these lines and the whole
focus of everything is on your face and
it's not just the words though that's
the thing it's not just lines you know i
mean if an actor's job was just
remembering lines it would be easy
um
you know what you're saying
is 10
of what you're actually doing you know
now as you're saying something as you're
answering someone's question is you're
dealing with someone that's seen there's
got to be 10 different ways you could
have responded to it but you've chosen
this one for some reason you know you
have to understand what the other nine
were you know
um so it isn't just it's not just lines
and that's what you're trying to get to
that point at which you can you
understand the sort of subterranean
aspect of the character
and then you can
we as viewers and as audience members we
can intuit very quickly what whether
someone
means what they say whether they're
thinking something else whether they're
hinting towards something you know those
are all
there's a whole
ton of nuance that you can bring to it
at that point
um before i run out of time with you i'm
very curious and excited for morbius uh
which is something you're a part of uh
what can you tease people about the
project and who you play
i'm not playing doc octopus like that
whole internet thing blew up about that
i've no idea where that came from it's
got nothing to do with me
i didn't hear that and that doesn't make
any sense for you to be playing that
character but that's a whole different
thing listen congrats on foundation
um thank you so much for your time